elle est dans sa famille depuis 1800 13
mai au décès de sa mère marie claude le
floch souhaite vendre cette statuette du
15e siècle estimé à 2 millions d'euros
problème le ministère de la culture s'y
oppose et la somme de restituer l'oeuvre
gratuitement elle décide de porter
plainte dans cette affaire si on si on
lutte c'est s'est pas uniquement dans
notre intérêt personnel
mais parce que ça peut créer une
jurisprudence qui fait que vous aurez
des tas de personnes qui possèdent des
biens appartenant à la famille royale ou
et c'est qu'ils auraient acheté et
qu'ils auraient conservé en toute bonne
foi et que tout d'un coup l'état peut
venir
demander la restitution si la justice
donne raison au ministère de la culture
ce plot rang en albâtre devra retourner
au musée des beaux-arts de dijon où se
trouve sa réplique en plâtre c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre de la culture du moyen-âge
qui a une valeur patrimoniale historique
architectural et artistique
imhof fait aussi l'histoire de notre
ville l'histoire des ducs de bourgogne
et un pour nous je ferais vraiment une
belle chance de l'accueillir à nouveau
ici à qui donc appartient ce plot rang
qui se pince le nez c'est une question à
plus de 2 millions d'euros qui partage
les dijonnais c'est bien que l'état
juste récupérer des oeuvres d'art qui
sont depuis sa devise et du public mais
à la fin voilà pas d'être une
indemnisation était correct en face à
nous dépasser quelque chose qui nous a
précédés et qui nous survivra peut-être
que le donner à nos enfants au sens très
large et sincèrement je les plains
j'aimerais position la justice devrait
trancher au début de l'année 2018 si son
droit de propriété n'est pas reconnue
marie-claude le floch envisage déjà de
porter l affaire devant la cour
européenne